c'est super politicien c'est à dire il
est général en chef d'une armée
c'est l'armé des socialistes qui se
battent contre l'armée on va dire des
ump des républicains il dit écoutez je
voudrais vous dire moi général en chef
de l'armée jeudi va falloir que vous
alliez pactiser tous ensemble tout ça
n'est pas crédible
tout ça n'est pas raisonnable tout ça
n'est pas sérieux il pense alors à
manuel valls d'ailleurs tous là j'en
sais rien j'en sais rien je compte sur
vous pour maîtriser parce que j'arrive
pas bien à comprendre
alors après il reste une question si les
socialistes et c'est grosso modo ce que
les sondages donnent arrive largement
distancé en troisième position ou plus
loin encore et qu'il ya un vrai risque
dans la région nord pas de calais
évidemment qu'il faudra appeler moi
j'appellerai alors responsabilités ont
retiré leurs responsabilités ça sera de
se retirer sur le samu et sans la
logique non mais moi je vous dis ce que
je pense
écoutez il est premier ministre il est
chef de bataille c'est très difficile je
trouve de faire de la politique de cette
façon là c'est parce qu'ils sont
porteurs
mais est ce qu'il le fait pour dire aux
socialistes vous demande pas à vous
retirer je vous dis comme ça vous aurez
quelques élus tout ça tout ça n'est pas
sérieux n'est pas raisonnable et c'est
vrai que je pense que marine le pen se
frotte les mains